right here you can't push and say that's
your take you saying I specifically
think this and they went no he's all out
to him you're not allowed an opinion I'm
not loud you know I never thought I'd
get to say this to your face but I
really admired your strategy with Piers
Morgan and I could tell because I've had
to debate him on TV before and I'm sat
on a flight on my own and I'm like okay
this is what I'm gonna get this is what
I'm gonna give back and you have to
manage him very well yeah and when I
watch that interview a part of me was
like is he going to be able to do what
he does best to make Tate look bad yeah
and you kind of nailed it in the sense
and I love how you kept looking at the
camera yeah you knew the clips you knew
what was coming yeah and you kind of
hijacked the whole conversation and
everyone went there to see you maybe
potentially trip up and Piers really
made you look good yeah it was certainly
a PR win like afterwards I was a little
bit mad at myself because I'm a
perfectionist but
my team analyzed the the comments on
every single video I've ever made
they're all I get a report every single
day of the entire internet what's said
about me what's good what's bad Etc and
Pierce Morgan was my highest performing
interview ever in regards to positive
versus negative 99.4 of comments are
positive in my favor so he lost like so
that's that's how you have to measure it
right with the metrics so I would like
to have said a lot more I could have
been a lot harder I could have destroyed
him but I now know the Matrix is looking
for me to trip up right so when they
come at me and try and say trying to get
me to say something about LGBT or try
and get me to say something about this
race or whatever they're trying to do I
can't give the machine more ammo so
especially with someone like peers I had
to be very careful with what I said
because that's what they're waiting for
because they can't restart the old
machine the misogyny thing is over they
still want me gone so they're waiting
for something they're still pumping the
misogyny [ __ ] that's if you ask anyone
who listens to the news about what they
think of Tate it's that he's still a
misogynist misogynistic oh like man like
I hate women like uh absolutely they're
gonna they're gonna because there's
always new people people coming into the
folds retards you know so the new people
they'll just start them off with the
evil stuff look at look at that crazy
look at our politicians still talking
about January 6th people can't afford
food and heat January 6th going on about
January 6th do people walk not that it
was okay nobody nobody advocated and
said it was okay but it was worse it was
worse than 9 11. drop dead that's I
can't believe so that's what they're
doing with this they'll just keep that
story going in the hopes that it just
keeps growing roots and catches new
flies so that's what they're going to do
with Tate but if somebody comes in and
sees something good with Tate a normal
level-headed interview he's intelligent
he's articulate he's successful and they
form their own opinion and then they
hear the misogyny stuff yeah they'll
probably believe it because people are
easily swayed but at least they'll have
some basis for something decent already
so gross the manipulation so gross it's
such horseshit you can't talk about
anything that doesn't fit with their
agenda without it backfiring on you I
can't even claim my YouTube plaque I
can't get the piece of metal because it
says you might have violated terms of
service even though we we haven't told
you well you know what being a bad kid
in the eyes of the thought police is a
damn good thing there's your medal right
there yeah I'll make a fake plaque and
I'll put it behind me some horse [ __ ]
though they're [ __ ] Metals I think
some of the shots you use with cheap
regarding this poor young girl I mean
that I've got dollars you know for me
and even if you haven't got kids you
know you're around kids all the time our
fan base your fan base yours yours our
youngsters and I was like
Bro you've got an agenda but don't be
sick and I like the way you brought that
up you know because that's like what the
[ __ ] you wanted some clickbait of you
saying to know what they were talking
about the Finish yeah it's it's and it's
also the algorithm was rewarding people
like when this whole Matrix attack
happened it was very orchestrated I knew
it was coming I knew I'd get to a point
where they were going to cancel me but I
didn't know it'd be as orchestrated as
it was so first the algo start rewarding
people who made a negative video of me
so my own team would make a video that
was positive of me and it would
basically get zero views but if you made
a negative video by Andrew Tate it was
always the top of every single one so
it's basically telling every YouTuber if
you do a negative agitate video that's
why I I that's why I formatted the
videos the oldest videos like um like we
were hating on Andrew Tate so that they
would do well I legit knew that you
scroll down to the bottom it's all like
us like acting we hate Andrew Tate but
inside the videos our real thoughts I
cracked the Matrix yeah it's funny
though that happened good mom reacts to
Tate's final message good
rest in peace rest in peace Bozo we've
had a lot of good times with Andrew Tate
so that's the first bribe right because
they don't give a [ __ ] right they want
views so that's the first thing and then
the way it was orchestrated amongst the
Charities and ngos and these activists
the way they all came out at the same
within three minutes bro within three
minutes with 150 different activists
post basically the same wording and
slightly Rewritten in the same picture
there's somebody above them behind them
that happens in so many situations that
happens in politics in covid there seems
to be some Mass some one puppet master
who will send out a script to actual
live news anchors and they'll all be
standing there you can look this up and
find Clips first unfortunately
oh my God it's terrifying when you think
of it because you're here you're
watching it just as a as a viewer and
you think you're getting actual news and
you're just getting some crazy ass
Puppet Master opinion oh it's Terror
it's terrifying and I love watching hate
that Tate is going through this but I
love how much exposure his story is
getting that he's just one more person
that were proof he's proving with what
he's going through
improving with what he's going through
that this is all orchestrated and every
thought we have is orchestrated and we
have to dig deeper we haven't said that
enough lately dig deeper don't believe
anything facts man I mean people will go
well I do I do I I listen to this news
and I listen to that news now did you do
the research yourself did you verify
that fact that you just spewed before
you said it and they'll go well I I
don't need to I I saw it and you're like
[ __ ] idiot just move on if they're
not willing to do that someone's not
willing to do the research just move on
don't even bother continuing a
conversation with them because they're
not an intellectual whoever they are
don't kill me I'd never kill myself
don't [ __ ] try but bro because that's
what's next that's what's next it's
scary I'm telling you everyone thinks
I'm paranoid everyone thinks I'm crazy
after yesterday he was I'm not sure what
I'm gonna release this but when he was
at the gym he came for a public workout
what I witnessed was insane illiteria
was people were trampled on the left
went out of all the people jumping will
live bringing signs pushing my assistant
and I was like I said to him in the
castle this is like that Kim Kardashian
Christian Ronaldo kind of level like
I've had a lot of these YouTubers here
I've had the Mayweather's the John
Cena's the khabibs but it's a different
kind of thing and I think where you've
been banned makes you more
can you tell me about this guy I don't
know who this is I don't know TK MMA fit
okay oh so he's maybe some sort of MMA
guy Prince back in the day the singer
you never saw him in interview you
didn't see them so it's like oh there's
Prince you know nowadays social media
like this whole influence I hate the
word influencer but yeah they're
everywhere you know they're everywhere
oh they're really celebs yeah I think
it's a little yummy it's a little bit
different as well with what do you think
influencers are celebrities I definitely
say so I feel like nowadays with people
looking at their phones so much they're
even more of celebrities if anything
it's so crazy they are I mean it's a
different type of celebrity and when you
think about how an influencer with a
million followers on Instagram or
something is making a really nice living
doing that really nice living and then
you and then I sometimes I think about
the real long-term household name
celebrities so that influencer with the
million Subs there's there's a section
of of the world population that knows
who they are and they're making money
off of them but then you think about
like just like big major how Hollywood
stars like the mega megas like uh who's
the biggest Hollywood star you can think
of think of like Leonardo DiCaprio yeah
like a DiCaprio or a or bread pit or
yeah you know what I was doing is I was
like what kind of influence and money
and power did they have if a regular
influencer is living in a mansion on the
beach it's crazy I always compare like
our YouTube watch time to other people
and like it's [ __ ] insane because
like like I think we're almost at two
million hours of watch time which is
like 200 years which is like sounds cool
and then you look at like the Dahmer
[ __ ] which has like a billion and it
goes back like 20 000 years like 20 000
years of watch time on the Dahmer [ __ ]
alone I'm like well I haven't done
that's like [ __ ] what is what is what
is two million compared to that you know
what I mean yeah but wow 20 000 years of
watch time I watched that you might
support him but he's not really doing
anything for you bar entertaining
Cristiano Ronaldo he may put a ball in
the net for you but with some of your
stuff about the Matrix I openly I use
the term a lot now and as soon as I use
a subtle one of your terms people come
at me for it but I escape the matrix by
accident when I became a personal
trainer I actually just wanted to do a
job I enjoyed and I made my own business
and I was like what I can expense stuff
yeah I mean business I'm going to work
in shorts and suddenly all my friends
that are doing pay as you earn again
really screwed over and then I was like
oh I'm gonna go to a fitness event in
you know somewhere foreign cauliflower
ear is really it makes me sad and it
freaks me out so you know you don't [ __ ]
with this dude though well
there are other ways you can be
unfuckable with without getting
cauliflower ear did I ever tell you
about that Lorraine's
um okay somebody she knew it doesn't
matter the actual connection but
somebody she knew had a kid who didn't
have ears
it's really terrible it's not funny why
are you laughing because because I have
a sick sense of humor but not because
they think it's funny so the kid was
disfigured and didn't have ears and they
used to have to um kind of like glue the
kids ear fake prosthetic ears on every
day before it went to school and I feel
really bad about this person and this
little kid had to go through this and
this was a long time ago so this child
is grown now thank God and doesn't have
to deal with this but I think at one
point there was something some new
technology where they got to like put in
a post of some sort so they could just
kind of like Slide the prosthetic ear on
so they didn't have to deal with gluing
and on hot day is the glue coming
unglued could you imagine my ear fell
off could you imagine being a little kid
and dealing with that like other little
kids were they deaf kids are so mean
were they deaf know that's a good
question kids are so mean wait both the
years were gone I believe it was two
ears it could have just been one what
are the odds it's been a long time all
right I'm also giving a hundred dollars
to someone who likes subscribes and
follows my Instagram so follow my
Instagram right here and subscribe and
like here too please we really
appreciate it yep okay
bye
[Music]
[Music]